all right right now let's turn to our
Kelly the troubled singer was taken into
custody this afternoon after a hearing
over unpaid child support this coming
just hours after the release of his
riveting interview with Gayle King now
Kelly's emotions bubbled over as he
defended himself against sexual abuse
charges we are the only show that spoke
to Gail about the interview and how she
remained calm in the eye of the storm I
thought a couple of times that maybe
were witnessing a breakdown as it's
happening he was very much aware of what
he was doing but I also thought that on
some level we were watching someone who
was really needed help and needed help
right away
Oprah called me sit are you okay are you
afraid I was never afraid I knew that he
was upset with me I knew that he didn't
like some of the questions but I never
thought that he was going to physically
attack me
Oprah praised her bestie tweeting Bravo
Gayle for calm and steady focus during
our Kelly interview I didn't see any
point in both of us overreacting our
Kelly became so emotional
Gale briefly pause the interview why
would I hold all these women in an
exclusive clip that airs in full
tomorrow on CBS this morning
Gayle asked if the performer has a kind
of split personality are there two are
Kelly's there's a Robert and there's a
are Kelly like what dr. Jekyll and mr.
Hyde all right but a little bit like
that absolutely not
seven weeks after lifetime aired the
documentary surviving are Kelly the
performer was charged with ten counts of
aggravated criminal sexual abuse of four
women three of whom or allegedly minors
at the time in the documentary the
parents of are Kelly's girlfriend
Joycelyn Sava
claimed she was being held against her
will today our Kelly's team released an
audio recording of Joycelyn telling them
that's not the case I have told you guys
a million million times that I am ok
where I am and I'm happy are Kelly also
had some harsh words for Lady Gaga Lady
Gaga's said as apologized for working
with you that portion also airs tomorrow
Lady Gaga it's very great talent it's
unfortunate that her intelligence go to
such a short level when it comes to that
I think he's disappointed that you know
people have turned their backs on him he
intends to keep making music and he
hopes that people will still listen to
his music now as of right now our Kelly
is in custody we will continue to update
this developing story it is this is a
wild one that was a while there goes to
Gayle she did
you